I think what makes Freddy special for a
lot of people is that he was always
played by the classically trained actor
Robert England but that almost wasn't
the case in 1985 during the production
of a Nightmare on Elm Street 2 Freddy's
Revenge new line Cinema wanted to save
money by just putting some nobody in a
rubber mask out there which would have
been funny but also very bad and the
studio realized that and England got his
check and probably a huge apology you
can still see the mask version of Freddy
right here but in this shot you can't
really tell but you can try to impress
your friends with that knowledge no one
will care hopefully they'll tell you to
get a grip on your life